I do my can I get a full English and a
black coffee that's all thank you might
have heard that inflation in the UK the
US and Europe was actually pretty low so
what does that mean for you and I at
breakfast I'm not a fat love the price
of food is going one way up for any
self-respecting Brit this is breakfast
allow me to present to you the full
English saturated fat stack of carbs a
shedload of salt and Kathy start with a
staple of any it's full English bacon
price the pork have pushed in higher
over in the US because of the deadly PDG
virus killing literally millions of
piglets a threat to supply later this
year we've been the humble piece of
toast is under pressure you've got a
drought in the u.s. southeast asia india
even australia predinner wheat prices
under pressure and all yes apparently
there's something going on in the
Ukraine the key grain producer then
you've got coffee people call this an
early morning drink I call it a
necessity it's all about one price
Brazil literally the world's biggest
producer of the stuff and there is a
drought in a country that is driving the
price of this Cup and the high so the
next time they tell you that inflation
is low and a thought for the humble
British breakfast
got a gym after this place nothing